make money online get rich quick
these are phrases we hear thrown around
a lot more these days
now that covet has wiped a lot of people
out left a lot of people
extremely desperate without jobs without
income
they're looking for a quick way to make
money online
on youtube or wherever they just want to
make money on the internet they want to
in the words of be has a get that wi-fi
bread
and there's nothing wrong with wanting
to support your family make money online
the problem is that there's liars on
youtube
who want to uh trick you into buying
things see
there's this niche of youtube called
make money online that has
exploded these videos are out of control
as you can see this is what happens if
you type and make money online
of course you get kevin david make
sixteen hundred dollars
fast and free searching google uh earn
three thousand dollars
copy and pasting no work make money
online
for free make money online watching
youtube videos get paid to click on ads
free app pays 500 per day worldwide no
surveys make money
online and you might be wondering is any
of this real
what's going on here what happened and
to learn
this is why i'm here to serve as a bit
of a
bit of a historian of the internet okay
because i'm i'm here
to take you back to understand what's
going on here
how weird this is why are they saying
like copy paste
why is everyone putting make money
online in the title you know why are
they using such gigantic numbers like
earn a thousand dollars on autopilot
with this free website to understand
that
guys we have to go back in time and we
have to talk about
goku okay well this took a weird turn i
swear i'm not a nerd
i'm trying to relate to you kitties
kiddos right
y'all care about dragon ball z is that
the new hip thing
uh is am i a boomer is this what does
nobody watch dragon ball z anymore
okay i i'm not gonna go deep here but if
you remember the show
there's something called power creep
that happens in dragon ball z
basically he's uh his super fighting
form super saiyan
he takes like forever to figure out how
to get to that
but once he gets to that level then
after that as a viewer you're kind of
bored if he just goes
super saiyan one right and so you gotta
go
super saiyan two and so then this is
where the power creep starts
and then oh well that's kind of boring
now now how can we push this further
right
oh oh we got to go further now i know
you're thinking steven
what the hell does that have to do with
making money online
okay to understand the make money online
space you have to understand that
everyone's trying to one-up each other
what used to be a big deal
is no longer a big deal to claim look
look look here's john christani
sort of the king of exaggerations on his
whiteboard he has
quick big money this is like i would say
john
is like the super saiyan level two of
fake gurus
right he's pretty far up there and he
was pretty extreme when he came out with
all his insane uh get rich quick claims
but here's what he says three quickly
and i'm going to walk you through this
method
step by step so that you can get a big
amount of money i'm talking nearly 500
sent straight to your bank account in
one day
okay so that's that's 2019 quick big
money
is 500 okay so now with that little
history lesson out of the way
let's go back and all of a sudden things
are going to make sense we're going to
go to
the investors channel this kid is who i
want to talk about today
this is the youtuber who honestly is
eliminating poverty with his videos it's
very impressive i mean all the make
money online
youtubers are eliminating poverty but
this kid especially because wait till
you see some of his videos
you know those like unicef commercials
where they're talking about like ending
hunger and poverty
children are dying every day from hunger
and sickness
that's because they haven't heard of the
investor nine months ago he was saying
earn 500
a day on autopilot nowadays
he's saying oh earn a thousand dollars a
day and now we are up to
twelve hundred dollars a day
five thousand dollars a day twelve
hundred dollars a day the power
creep has gotten to the point that his
latest video
is 2 000 in 30 minutes
for free done for you
[Music]
this is the gig dude this is super
saiyan 3
3.0 right so this is his video this is
the pinnacle
of make money online content and i want
you to notice
you know he really emphasizes how much
work you need to do to get this stuff
done he really makes it hard on you
no selling no camera no investment and
no
social media followers
in fact you don't even have to lift a
finger screw it dude on that
i'm gonna throw out the believability
right away if you clicked on this video
yeah
maybe you're not so bright two thousand
dollars a day in 30 minutes for free
done for you
dude even get rich quick scammers are
like okay come on you got to be a little
realistic are you kidding
30 minutes for free done for you
guys if this were real and he says it's
worldwide by the way so
don't don't worry if you're not in
america right it's worldwide this works
all around the world and i even did the
hardest part
for easy street guys we're on easy
street
this man's eliminating poverty i want
you to appreciate that guys
so it's worldwide it's done for you can
someone please tell alyssa milano
that they need to talk to the investor
please i can't do it by myself guys
every like on this video is a message
sent to alyssa milano
but with your support in just 50 cents a
day
we can 50 cents a day dude
that's nothing if everyone would just
could watch
the investor that's the name of the
channel the investor
they'd all be making 32 000
every day for eight hours of work that's
how much money you can make if you make
two thousand dollars every thirty
minutes
four thousand dollars an hour eight
thousand or thirty two thousand dollars
for eight hours
oh my gosh and look i wouldn't be
talking about it if people didn't
believe it
look at this stuff hey guys let's make
money online we can do this
uh not on you not here you can't and
really what he's doing is
the the real genius behind this if you
ask me is you're collecting
a a short list of all the sheep on
youtube
okay if you think about what advertising
get rich quick scams do
is it basically creates a lead list a
hot list
for who's interested in get rich quick
scams and then you can sell them a get
rich quick scam because as we know a lot
of these courses they're just get rich
quick schemes
so uh yeah look at that he's selling a
course of course he is
let's go check that out surely this
isn't a get-rich-quick scheme
he said sarcastically setting up the
next segment
are you ready to make ten thousand
dollars per month on youtube
no camera no bs no affiliate marketing
no work
but here's my favorite part so he's got
a video pitching it or whatever
it's like 300 bucks this is my favorite
part though
at the bottom this is not a get rich
quick program
it's like bernie madoff saying uh this
is not a ponzi scheme
hey this is before you invest want you
to know not a ponzi scheme
or it's like herbalife being like hey
guys just so we're clear
we are not a pyramid scheme want you to
be clear on that
and they're like showing you their comp
plan it's
triangle shaped it's not actually a
pyramid
but the crazy thing i think to me is
that this guy's getting real views i
mean at the end of the day he's getting
like
legitimate views on his channel um
from posting this crap and what it shows
is that is that there's a real audience
for this
there's a hunger for get rich quick
content
and of course there's because we're in
the middle of a pandemic so
it it frustrates me because you know as
somebody who's trying to protect people
from this stuff i feel almost helpless
that's why i need you guys to smash like
on this video so we can notify more
people of this
these scams but um two months ago
almost half a million views step one and
that's not
because it's a good video it's just
because people are searching the stuff
left and right they want they're
desperate to make money
that's all there is to it and this guy
is stealing their money selling them
worthless courses or just wasting their
time with this crap
look at this i'm just trying to help my
mama pay the bills the way she did for
me
it's sad to say this ain't gonna do it
bruh
what do you expect typing in make money
online into youtube
unfortunately it's just this it's it's a
hot term right now because this guy's
basically promising he's gonna eliminate
poverty and the truth is he's helping
keep people
in the poor house also he can enrich
himself from his course
oh by the way before we leave i just
wanted to point out you know that course
i showed you earlier this course right
here
it's just caleb maddox like 2.0 it's
just another youtube course
and what he's really going to teach you
is how to make make money online
videos with a bunch of b-roll like he
does
you can be just like him scamming other
people see it's a ponzi scape
he's at the top you buy his course you
start making
content to trick other people and
they'll get scammed until they decide to
start scamming other people and we can
just all scam each other
but anyways i hope this was educational
uh on the
the weird power creep in in uh
make money online stuff to the point of
insanity and just to let you guys know
like
if you've got friends in your life who
watch this stuff who are
on that uh you know who are on that make
money
online grind remind them how many scams
there are out there it's
so bad look at this two thousand dollars
a day
no work he's sleeping that's a fire
thumbnail i'm not gonna lie this is not
a get rich quick program
all right guys see ya and don't forget
to smash
like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
comes along